ah
[Music]
I'm Greg I'm John we're going to talk
today about Annabelle creations right we
just came back one of the noisiest movie
theater experiences we've ever had not
because the crowd was scared but because
a couple of teenagers who probably snuck
into this r-rated flick would not shut
up the entire time John had a great time
there right next to it so this movie is
directed by David F Sandberg who did
lights out I said and this is a one of
those like sequel prequel things it's a
prequel to prequel to enema pre-boot
it's approve it is the word for a lot of
ways I was thinking a ouija origin of
evil when I was watching this definitely
not just because Louie Wilson who is
also an Ouija origin of evil is in this
- I didn't register that from the
trailer I was watching that a couple
days early who's the origin of evil yeah
and this is you know a seat this is one
of those pre boots as John puts it it's
a period piece and it's meant to
reinvigorate the franchise to reboot
territory it's a female-driven centric
cast the film is pretty good though it
was really good I like this this trend I
will say like I'm a little weary about
it becoming the new cookie cutter I do
like this trend of basically taking
something that maybe didn't work modern
day especially these more supernatural
movies and transcribing them into the
past even though I don't want this to be
the solution to every problem you know I
think what worked really well for Ouija
also works really well here because it
does make it more of a spooky yeah ghost
story gives it that sort of ghost tale
feel you know more so though that
modern-day does and I really enjoyed
this film from beginning to end
I heard a couple of reviews prior to us
filming while I was setting up I was
listening to a few reviews on YouTube
and I gotta say I disagree with what a
lot of people say about the first half
of this movie a lot of people were
saying like the first half is slow kind
of dull and I don't think that I got
what this film was doing from the very
beginning I thought that it was just
building up really establishing
characters really establishing
environment this set up of the story is
this couple who loses a daughter 12
years later after they lose their
daughter they open up their home to an
orphanage just with a few
women and not two minutes like a nun and
then a few girls and the introduction
into the girls seeing this home that
they're going to be living at kind of
reminded me of don't breathe a little
bit if you have there's a really long
tracking shot a lot of panning around
really getting to know the inside of the
house and now the entire house works and
it reminded me of don't breathe in the
sense that this would be the playground
or where everything is going to go down
for how all this is going to end up
becoming a horrifying experience in the
end yeah there's like jump scares
throughout the first half a lot but they
don't bother me I thought a lot of a
pretty good jump scare so the most part
actually David Sandberg has proven
himself at least with all the shorts and
with these two features now like that he
is pretty clever about his horror yeah
stuff you know and even the jump scares
are still pretty creative I know the
first Annabelle wasn't too well-received
bringing in David Sandberg for Annabelle
creation was a great choice because his
style is very similar to James Wan style
I don't know how heavily involved James
Wan was in producing this film but the
direction the types of angles the
tracking shots the pans the way he
doesn't really show much gore going on
when it comes to demonic stuff it a lot
of it is really good at teasing the
demonic stuff total things or even
though he's happening in the background
yeah yeah details places that make you
uneasy there's a momma Reese I remember
where we see Annabelle if you were like
cool and I was like what and then I see
like oh there's some ice or something
else behind her yeah they're very hard
to pin you have to I pay attention to
the full picture and the film is shot
wonderfully and it's the acting isn't
really good to two specific actresses
stood up to me in this film were two
Lisa Bateman who plays Janice she's the
girl he seen the trailer as a polio
disease yeah she walks without he's on
that heylia guy she's nothing
she has polio disease and the Lulu
Wilson who we saw in Ouija origin of
evil and these two girls are fantastic
in the film what stood out to me about
this film too similar to how the
conjuring is this woman's really an
unsolvable piece you got a wide range of
characters here you got like you know
the to bully girls and then you got the
two girls who are like or view
themselves as sisters and want to be
adopted together
you got the couple who lost their
daughter you got a couple other kids we
don't get to know very yeah you got the
know
who's watching over them yeah and the
film does a pretty damn good job of not
losing its central focus on the Janus
character while still cutting around to
these other characters but without it's
a really good in samba piece because
this is a situation that affects
everybody you know even though like the
the brunt of the haunting happens to
certain characters more than others this
whole situation affects everybody else
and it does do a nice job jumping back
and forth between Janos and that leads
to some pretty cool set piece and
there's a lot more creature effects than
I was expecting practical effects or
some pretty good CGI it's not heavy on
CGI yeah they seem like they really used
it where they needed it yeah that was a
good choice like that's a smart choice
there's some great sound design some
awesome buildup of tension throughout
like the first half of this film I get
why some people complain about it
because it is the slower part of the
film but it's all building up because
the finale like maybe the last 30 to 40
minutes somewhere there is insane it's
like a real ride yeah yeah the finale of
this movie does get really yeah it goes
it you know okay it's a really intense
finale it is awesome the Annabelle
mythology is built in an even better way
I think then we've had before I started
to understand how a lot of this works a
lot better I feel like a lot of times we
watch horror movies as an audience
member a lot of times as an audience um
where you can feel like you're smarter
than the characters that are endemic um
and this film is not filled with that
especially because you can be a lot more
forgiving because at the time this movie
takes place in the lack of resources
they have they're in an isolated
environment and it is you know a ghostly
and somewhat demonic situation happening
to bunch of people who are very safe
absolutely although without giving too
much away there's a carrot it's a horror
movie characters are going to die
there's one time when a character dies
where when they're dead body is found
it's not like they had a heart attack
it looks like the wither solely out out
of them only like the ring yeah yeah
it's a lot like that and then the way
the main characters kind of just brush
it off like oh is probably
you know I had a heart attack or
something yeah I know gosh we're eagerly
been warning you about this rising demon
ghost stuff going on a heart attack it's
a clear resemblance of that yeah as the
only time in the movie where I'm like
come people started laughing one the
very next shot that none characters like
alright girls get back to bed at people
in the audience are laughing because
that was the one time room like that was
a stupid character decision right there
other than that though the film is
definitely not filled with that a lot of
times I feel like the characters are
kind of smart the Lulu Wilson character
at times is very isolated has to outwit
the demon I think she does a really good
job in every decision she's making a lot
of the time too you know you're you're
with kids you know you're you're with
kids and they're kind of isolated you
know even though there is a certain
number of adults around it tends to
change you know you are kind of that
makes this situations that much more
intense because absolutely you know you
are watching children try and invade you
know horrifying nests yeah and one thing
I credit the somme on to is how they
handle the prologue of the film that was
one of the first things I was telling
John after the movie was done a lot of
times in horror movies when you have a
prologue it's kind of just this
expositional setup thing or a tease or
something that gets elaborated on much
later in the film the way this prologue
is done you're pretty much sold this is
the beginning of the film and this is
how the film is going to proceed from
here on out and then when it has a
sudden moment where it cuts to Annabelle
creation I'm like oh I've invested in
this one for like ten minutes already
and yeah yeah that is a nice organic way
to open the story up and again it gives
it gives it that ghost tale clown feel
you know that's something I really like
about what they're doing with this it
does feel like it's fit nicely into the
conjuring world without it being like
hey gonorrhea right yeah there's a
couple of Easter Eggers a post-credits
scene you know like that's setting up a
completely separate movie that has
nothing to do with Annabelle you know
they are doing that they are building
their universe but it's it really are
doin truce no it's not super duper
in-your-face
I feel felt like David Sandberg in the
studio set out to make a really good
movie that was setting out to do a good
moved on what would happen after the
first Annabelle solo movie happened they
wanted to just make a really good movie
and not worry too much on universe
building although there is a couple of
teases there it's really not
in-your-face there are a couple of
teases to things that we already know
exists yeah I know it's that kind of a
thing this movie really got me to
understand the universe they are
building at this religious horror
universe they're building which I really
do love a lot like religious [ __ ] one
of my favorite horror genres it's like
three out of four of these films are
pretty damn good films yeah
yeah well it seems like they they care
about the right things and they're you
know making some interesting choices
it's like you know having this ensemble
of different girls together you know in
this house with this odd you know
dollmaker guy and his yeah his wife
who's like kept in the next ruling it's
kind of an intriguing situation and it
doesn't kind of unfold all on its own
like it's nice that it feels isolated
the cast is all good even even
epicanthal ooh Talia and and Miranda
Otto who you know aren't the hugest
characters in the movie they don't have
like tons of dialogue necessarily
Miranda Otto's the only character who
has this one scene where you're like
boom a lot of exposition yeah yeah and
it was nice to have a real honest Creon
her I think Miranda Otto is terrific but
asking Natalia is really good in the
film too yeah and a lot of his
performance is in his face and his body
language you know just a lot of it is in
the history we know about him not so
much the dialogue he's spitting out of
it absolutely I don't know if I like
this quite as much as say we Georgian of
evil I think this may be you know the
script could have been a little tighter
I did like it didn't help the screen but
I did like that it is kind of a quiet
movie and there's a lot of silence and
there's a lot of like room tones that
yeah you know the now sounds great yeah
yeah so you know I think this is a
successful step in the right direction
as far as the the cinematic universe
game is going the people making the
conjuring right now have one of the more
solid like I get what you're trying to
do and it seems like you're focused on
making good movies and you know making
slightly in some ways at least different
choices so all I'd say this is just a
really solid entry into the conjuring
universe where it seems like most
audiences and I can see why I think it's
a great
up up after the last Annabelle solo
outing alright reject nation did you see
Annabelle creation do you prefer it over
the first Annabelle do you prefer the
first Annabelle oh you're kind of alone
there you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification Bell
Diaz - on Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram